we just can't help ourselves if it's
interesting spider-man stuff we're gonna
check it out we're gonna watch the day
from geom films he did tom hall last
week we reacted to his toby mcguire one
and now he's got andrew garfield reacts
to the spider-man no way home trailer i
actually spoke to george that's the geo
in the name of gom films i spoke to him
on the phone for like 25 minutes a few
hours ago the dude is such a nice guy so
happy to know him and so happy that he
uh supports us you know covering his
videos once in a while but yeah just
getting to actually know him personally
was was a true delight george you rock
man if you haven't subscribed to gom
films please do yourself a favor and do
it today puts up a ton of content way
more that we react to and also from
talking with him too you know like i can
confirm this this takes a lot of hard
work and he was giving me some insight
into his process so yeah man this is uh
toby mcguire hit like 2.2 million views
well deserved let's watch this one now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh i remember i broke her neck oh my god
that's a little team i'm sorry i'm sure
please we're safe to have the universe
together i think we're beyond you
calling me sir okay
stephen
i was wondering if maybe you
cast that spell
it's too dangerous
yes i agree
i won't
that was right decision hey
uh you lied
you
[Applause]
oh that's the green goblins oh my god
nice goblin reference come on i know who
this is
yep
dr octavius
oh man i never fought him no
subscribe please
please
you know what i noticed about
your editing with some of these
characters is that some of the delivery
is so funny because you're making sure
that the words will match with the mouth
so the delivery sometimes has to be
stretched out in a weird way yeah just
like right there subscribe
yeah
it makes it feel that much more real
even though it's not a perfect
one-to-one match to his voice obviously
and you know what i really appreciate
about this one especially coming off the
heels of the tobey maguire one toby
maguire seemed to have kind of like a
cocky not as enthused reaction towards
the trailer but here the spirit that you
capture with andrew garfield is like why
you're not like trying to do an andrew
garfield voice or something like that
the energy from the injury that you
pulled from here really has a lot more
enthusiasm in terms of reacting to the
trigger like oh my god i'm shocked you
know it's such a funny ass moment and
then of course a couple of little dicks
here there like oh i almost fought him
because the sinister six we all know
that was supposed to happen or how like
the whole world forgot that i was
spider-man too you know so there's a lot
of really good jokes in here but i love
how it doesn't feel like just repetitive
jokes from toby mcguire or the one from
tom holland that you're still capturing
sort of like the essence of the energy
that they give off in the interview and
matching it for a trailer reaction so to
me it's really really clever i know it
takes a lot of time and a lot of work to
read those lips to try to make it match
so yeah kudos again another fantastic
job did i leave anything for you to say
did i leave anything at all i know i
kind of just
did it i just said the same things you
said but with slightly different
reference points like ah it really made
me think of the energy he had in the
werewolf interview so great way to pull
that at the end of like kevin feige
actually giving him the call and stuff
funny stuff man guys subscribe to geoff
films if you haven't done so already
these are such a laugh right every every
single time we cover these are always so
damn funny
hit that like button i'll catch you guys
soon
[Music]